we live here together  and we are together making it all happen  and for people who want to fight against  us go somewhere else please don't bother  us in Las Vegas  strong words for those thinking about  causing trouble in Las Vegas as mayor  Carolyn Goodman delivers her final state  of the city address tonight at City Hall  and during the speech she talked about  how far our city has come since the  pandemic  we're finally able to put covid for the  most part behind us we weathered through  the shutdown and we're still having the  after effects of that and then all the  fear that each of us experience moving  forward though as only Las Vegas has  always done and always can and will do  mayor Goodman is term Limited at the end  of this year so this is her final state  of the City address